and finally new rule if you can't read
you can't be president
now i know donald trump is a stable
genius but he
he handles a teleprompter about as well
as the real housewives handle
wine that's why it took him an hour and
a half to sound out the state of the
union address
the man is an after-school special
waiting to happen
he read so slowly
they had to set the teleprompter speed
to shatner
[Applause]
now of course the president can read a
little
fdr could dance a little
but
those are the people you have to talk to
i'm sending you out there
but according to michael wolff for trump
quote if it was in print it might as
well not exist some believe that for all
practical purpose he was no more than
semi-literate ooh burn
i'm pretty sneaky a wolf to put it where
trump will never see it
in a book
[Applause]
today we learn that trump does not read
the presidential daily briefing as every
other president has members of the
national security council say the only
way to get him to read a memo
is to stick his name in every paragraph
because he keeps reading if he's
mentioned
like a baby will keep eating his peas if
you go here comes the airplane every
time
[Applause]
you could tell trump has not taken in
new information
for decades because he's always saying
most people don't know that
[Laughter]
about things that most people do in fact
know
nobody knew that health care could be so
complicated
abraham lincoln most people don't even
know he was a republican
people don't realize we are an
unbelievably divided country
people don't know this about iraq but
they have among the largest oil reserves
in the world
he writes it himself doesn't he
here's a picture of trump hard at work
have you ever seen an empty or desk
no need for pen paper or any device it's
all up here baby
and that is possibly the worst thing
about him his certainty
that all he knows is all anybody would
ever need to know
psychologists call this the
dunning-kruger effect the tendency of
ignorant people
to think they're much smarter than they
are usually it's harmless and just leads
to rock bands making concept albums
about robots
[Applause]
but it gets scary when it leads to a
president who thinks global warming
isn't real because it still snows
trump says i like reading as little as
possible
i don't need you know 200 page reports
on something that can be handled on a
page
he's actually proud that he makes
decisions without learning anything
which makes him the perfect president
for a nation perpetually looking at its
phone
illiteracy isn't trump's shame it's his
bond
with us a subliterate president for a
sub-literate country
a country where a majority of adults get
their news from facebook and 24
of teenagers are almost constantly
online
mostly with james franco
a quarter of americans say they haven't
read a book in the past year and the
other three quarters are lying
lately the hottest thing in publishing
has been adult
coloring books which you can find in the
bookstore in this section marked
seriously
[Applause]
people will always say i love to read
but don't dig into that
too deep what they mean is they went to
barnes and nobles to buy a cat calendar
and on the way out picked up yet another
book on cooking in the miracle pot
or a self-help book or one of the many
stories of a boy who dies and meets
jesus in heaven
and comes back to life or some nonsense
it's really for juveniles
like harry potter or twilight i mean
there's reading
and then there's reading fifty shades of
gray is to literature what candy corn is
to vegetables
and i hate to tell you facebook is not a
place
to read in the sense of garnering real
and valuable information
facebook is what replaced reading
so you'd have more time to take pictures
of your dick
and no sorry staring at your phone
doesn't make you a reader
any more than watching fireworks makes
you an astronomer
or getting a [ __ ] stamp makes your ass
a museum all right
you